[Music]
the upcoming Knives Out sequel has
another stacked cast but it's the
surprise cameos that are sure to get
people talking who shows up will the
film be darker than the first here's all
you need to know before the big premiere
in November 2019 writer and director
Ryan Johnson made waves with his murder
mystery film Knives Out the acclaimed
who done it earned rave reviews and
raped in a seriously impressive pull at
the box office against a relatively
modest budget which is saying nothing of
its multiple Golden Globe nominations
luckily for all the legions of Knives
Out fans out there neither Craig nor
Johnson hesitated to express their
interest in revisiting detective Benoit
Blanc in fact drawing a pre-golden
Globes party held by Lionsgate in
January 2020 Johnson told The Hollywood
Reporter that he was already working on
a script for a Knives Out sequel
following the world premiere of
glasenian at the 2022 Toronto
International Film Festival Johnson
reminds the door keep making knives out
sequels for as long as his style lets
him via variety he joked I'm going to
keep making these until Daniel blocked
me on his phone it sounds crazy but
it'll work however despise how much he
clearly enjoys making his Craig LED who
done it Johnson did some how the Los
Angeles Times that he found writing
Glass Onion to be a particularly
difficult experience Johnson shared it
was scary I also spent 10 years planning
Knives Out whereas this I was kind of
starting from scratch fortunately if the
films overwhelmingly positive early
reviews are any indication it looks like
Johnson already has the excuses he needs
to keep making his Knives Out sequels
the main creative team members behind
Knives Out began working on a sequel
only a few months after the film's
release so it shouldn't come as much of
a surprise to learn that Glass Onion and
lives out mystery is said to be released
relatively shortly for his part Daniel
Craig likely had a little more time to
spare for Glass Onion too given the fact
that his tenure as James Bond came to an
end in 2021 with no time to die all of
which to say that Knives Out fans don't
have to wait much longer to see the
follow-up to that beloved 2019 who'd
done it indeed a Glass Onion is
currently set to premiere Friday
December 23rd on Netflix Ryan Johnson
also announced on Twitter in early
October that Glass Onion will be
released in Select theaters one month
prior to its late December Netflix
Premiere that means Knives Out fans will
get the chance to see glass and Ian
early though the film is only set to
play in theaters throughout the week of
November 23rd
Glass Onion the knives out mystery will
tell a completely different story than
his predecessor according to Netflix's
tadum Ryan Johnson's Knives Out sequel
will be set in the Mediterranean and
will follow Edward Norton's Tech
billionaire miles Braun and the friends
he invites to his private island in
Greece as you might have already guessed
one of these friends ends up dead and
it's Daniel Craig's Benoit Blanc who is
ultimately tasked with discovering the
identity of the victim's murderer this
was the case in knife's house to new
film's wealthy Central characters will
all be far from perfect while speaking
with sadum Johnson even touched on the
relationships at the center of Glass
Onion saying it's structured around a
group of friends or Frenemies who all
have a power Dynamic with one of their
successful friends it begins with him
sending an invitation for them to come
and play this murder mystery game at
this exotic Locale fans will
unfortunately have to wait to find out
not only who the key victim is in Glass
Onion but to his ultimately responsible
for their death really Duke oh my God
really
knives elbows did some pretty impressive
star power in addition to Daniel Craig
the film's cast included Heavy Hitters
like Anna diamos Jamie Lee Curtis Tony
Collette Chris Evans Don Johnson Jaden
Martell Michael Shannon Catherine
Langford and Ricky Lindholm the Keith
Stanfield also turned in a memorable
performance in knives out as detective
Lieutenant Elliot while Noah seagan made
a lasting impression as Trooper Wagner
fortunately Glass Onion a Knives Out
mystery seems to have assembled a
similarly impressive Ensemble of actors
not only will glassonian Center once
again around Craig's Benoit Blanc but
the long-awaited knives out sequel will
also introduce viewers to a new lineup
of eccentric characters indeed while no
knives our cast members outside of Craig
are expected to appear in Glass Onion
the new films cast does feature
recognizable Stars this includes Kate
Hudson Edward Norton Catherine Hahn Dave
Batista Ethan Hawke Madeline Klein
Jessica henwick Leslie Odom Jr and
Janelle Monae plus spoiler alert for
what will likely be fun cameos the film
will Mark the final on-screen
appearances of two late Legends Stephen
Sondheim and Angela Lansbury in other
words it seems safe to say that Glass
Onion has managed to successfully steal
at the very least one page from its
predecessor's Playbook
[Music]
Glass Onion a Knives Out story is just
like the original Knives Out was rated
PG-13 the film's rating is reportedly
due to strong language drug content some
violence and sexual material taking that
into account it sounds like glastenium
will be a bit edgier and more mature
than some parents may be comfortable
with for whatever it's worth 2019's
Knives Out was rated PG-13 for drug
material brief violence sexual
references some strong language and
thematic elements in other words it
sounds like glastonium will have worse
language and sexual references than
Knives Out There whether or not
glastonian ends up being considerably
darker in tone and content than knives
out however remains to be seen parents
should nonetheless note the differences
between the two films PG-13 ratings if
they're debating whether or not to take
their kids to Sea Glass Onion later this
year
[Music]
foreign
[Music]